[Music]
this is chess openings explained and
tonight I thought we would take a look
at the Milner Barre gambit which comes
out of the French defense and it is a
very aggressive option that white has so
if you're looking for a weapon against
the French and you want to sacrifice
upon to get really active pieces this is
a good opening for you and what I
particularly like about it is that even
with obstructive some really strong
players about this and even players that
you know done their homework and know
what they're talking about have sort of
conflicted feelings on this opening a
lot of people say it's just cost you
lose upon and a lot of people say no you
get a lot of compensation and people
have quite a lot of different thoughts
about certain lines than this opening so
I thought we'd take a look at it because
it's a very interesting opening and it
does come out of the French defense so
here we have it in tonight we'll be
focusing on the advanced variation and
okay even this some people have
different thoughts about because it does
release the tension in the center so you
can protect it with upon or even
protected with a knight and I could see
three or 9:52 so like it's to play his
natural black break c5 why typically
bolsters the center so if you take I can
take back with a pawn
okay and we're going to look at sort of
the main line here in the advance they
attack d4 then they attack it again now
there's two moves that are more popular
than what we're going to look at the
most popular move is a three with the
idea of b4 forcing black to do something
with attention here also very reasonable
with Bishop e2 and you can just castle
and get sort of a normal game but
tonight we're going to look at what
happens if you put your bishop on the
most natural square okay this is just
the best square for that Bishop and I'm
just going to put it there and this
obviously temps black into taking on d4
so and there is a little trap here and
originally I was just kind of going to
brush by this trap and be like you know
yeah you know no one will ever fall for
this but I
having played a few practice games this
week with it like it so decent people
have just fallen for the trap so like it
says something not everybody knows if
black just goes ahead and wins the wins
the pond
does anybody know this trap for the
reputation yeah in the back uh-huh yeah
excellent so this can happen and then
obviously you lose a queen and sometimes
beginners they just go look good they
won the Queen but okay a little more
precise as Trading bishops first and
then winning the Queen so there's this
little trap and okay depending on your
your level people may or may not
actually fall for this trap but it's
going to be a good idea that before the
knight takes the black plays Bishop d7
so this idea doesn't work now the most
popular move here and we'll come back to
see what happens
there's another option if black just
decides right away to play this it gives
quite an additional option but let's
just get to the gambit and hopefully we
have time we'll come back to it so in
this position after trading you can now
play Bishop to d7 and you are
threatening to take on d4 and it doesn't
really make sense to play some Bishop
moves there's some problems with both of
those moves and you don't want to move
the same thing so we just castle and now
black really should take so this is the
starting point of the gambit and what's
the point of this why are you giving up
the pawn on d4 well White's going to
focus on getting its pieces out really
quickly and you'll often gain a lot of
time attacking the black Queen so we
invite her in to our territory and now
the move that we can play it's a bit
provocative so hopefully if you're gonna
play in the tournament tonight you you
pay attention to this move here Knight
to c3 and so you're offering sort of a
double pawn sacrifice and most players
don't accept it and I've heard a lot of
people just
about you know the reputation of this
opening you just play a move like a six
you don't let any of the pieces go to be
five often the knight or a bishop wants
to go to be five for white so you don't
allow it you don't want to take the
second pun but I I think actually taking
the pawn might be all right for black
you have to know what you're doing but
it is a very interesting thing to
consider so we'll take a look at both
lines obviously the first thing we want
to think about is well what happens if
they just take the pond because if there
are two ponds for no reason like two
swims but we'll have a look at it and
we'll see that it it's not so easy to
play either side really it gets quite
complicated quite quickly
in the sound you can come in alright
welcome guys
do you hear that song no I want you to
you know do what do what we do
yeah you're gonna have to go get that
whistle okay so here the point is we
play the move rook to e1 so black is up
to pawns but white is developing pieces
very rapidly and now we have lots of
ideas like we can take here if there's a
pin on this pond so that's a potential
idea often this night might go here the
bishop might use the be 5 square we
might sometimes sacrifice on e6 that's
actually a common theme that we're going
to explore and in general we're doing
very good as white if we get to play the
move Bishop that for often accompanied
by rook to c1 we get lots of control
over c7 and it's quite possible that
white can just blow black off the board
if black plays slightly inaccurate here
and I want to focus on two different
moves here that have been tried Bishop
are clean to b8 which is probably the
best move even though it it does let you
take here on d5 so black gives back upon
but he remains upon up so we'll come
back to that the greediest is Queen to
d6 because now this isn't a tactic
because the Queen takes but in this
position white has a pretty strong move
Knight to d5 and this asks black a
really interesting question if you have
to take with your Bishop which is what
most people do when I take care it means
your king is going to remain in the
center for the rest of the game and you
can argue that's fine I'm two pawns up
I'm going to defend and then I'm going
to be two pawns up but the other option
which is just bad but let's also played
them quite frequently is Queen to b8 and
it might not be obvious at first why
this is a bad move but white actually
has a really strong move here so I'm
going to give you guys a chance just to
think about this position now see if you
guys can find the best move for white
because if you find
right move in the right plan here then
black is already in a lot of trouble
Queen c2 what's your your idea is you're
going to check me here layer idea and I
just see seven that's your idea so I
kind of go to the fund in this position
Bishop f4 so this is the idea this is
the move that you definitely want to
play there's a huge problem with it
though you know that that's the problem
but you're on you're on the right idea
so you need to somehow make it possible
for us to play Bishop to f4 on g3 is
okay but it is a little bit slow you
want to get your pieces out as quickly
as possible because you're down to pawns
so to order to prove the biggest
advantage you want to get all of your
your stuff going and this is okay since
you're going to play here again I
probably have to go here and you can
trade and play Bishop f4 and this should
be okay for you after say this
I still think what has a lot of
compensation if you play this way but
you can play an even stronger move and
get more pieces involved Queen f3 good
yeah clean f3 is a super strong move
here for white and the idea is just to
play Bishop to f4 so which really can't
be allowed but now we can take this
Bishop and play Bishop to f4 and you can
kind of see the problems if we just go a
couple more moves if Queen e7 which
defends against tactics if we take here
because there's not a direct pin anymore
but
if black spawns move up so here it's
white to move okay yeah the problem here
is that this is attacked by two things
and defended by one so either capture is
probably super strong that's not
attacking you're clean and I'm going to
move my bishop and discovery yeah so
yeah we do have to be really careful but
if you just look at a line like Queen to
e7 a very strong move here is Queen to
g3 eyeing the Jeep on the bishop will
come into d6 and white just has a very
strong position and it's it's definitely
worth the pawns you've given up here
because you're already attacking that
just goes to show you how quickly it can
go downhill for black so as the black
side you got to be really careful so if
you do want to play the Queen's of the
six line it's probably worth taking a
look at the lines that occur after you
take that night away because that Knight
is pretty strong but now after we take
back it's pretty obvious that you're
going to be stuck in the center so you
can play King g8 and say yeah it's not
the best but I'm up to pawns and lots of
different moves have been played here I
just will show one line though a very
interesting line is Queen to h5 so you
are attacking the pawn and if they
defend
there was a URI schulman game if I'm
remembering right and in that game he
played Bishop to f4 and got a pretty
good advantage but perhaps even stronger
is Bishop to g5 after which you have to
play Knight to f6 and White has a very
strong pressure also after Queen f3 has
some strong pressure here for the pawns
but we can make a funny mistake we can
play a move f6 it's just a funny mistake
and we can continue making funny moves
if you go here and you think you have a
threat here I can play ro K to d1
because you can't really capture them on
your queen but this was one of
my practice games this week so but it
just shows you black can get into a lot
of trouble really quick and it's not
easy because after a queen age five you
already got to think about defensive
moves against this pond and all of white
stuff is coming into play very quickly
but if we return let's go back quite a
bit
so they take our pond Knight c3 offering
the second pawn and after rook e1 will
look at the move Queen to b8 which is a
much better try here for black okay this
gives one pawn back so black is still
ahead upon but the Queen is a lot safer
on b8 and now why just thinking again
about the move Bishop to f4 that's one
of the moves are trying to get in early
on so black in semi force to play the
move Bishop to d6 now he's eyeballing
the H fun which is good it's a threat
but white can actually ignore this and
make a threat of his own which is what
you want to do when you're down material
you can play Queen to g4 introducing the
idea of taking on g7 and if the King
moves over which it should there's a pin
against this Bishop here so sometimes
that becomes a thing you can take right
here right away and actually it gets
pretty complicated but it should be
complicated in White's favor so after we
move over for example now if you play
King f8 to the Thunder pond
we can play g3 and we trap your bishop
but it's actually really complicated it
should all work out for white but you do
have ideas such as Queen to b6 which
attacks this and breaks this pin you
have ideas of just taking here first and
then Queen to d6 and really complicating
stuff can happen but it should work out
for white we can make one more funny
blunder before we go to King f8 I we can
play g6 defending the stuff and losing
immediately so again I'll give you guys
a minute it seems like a move people
might be tempted to make a reserve
rights to castle I didn't play King f8
I just offended my thing but who can
find the game winner right here so we
want to take advantage of the weakness
of the last move clean before yes very
strong eyeballing the rook and there's
really no easy way to defend against it
so this is a pretty hopeless f6 we're
going to stick with our Knight
if here now there's a pin and the best
move here is really funny it's the move
you always want to play so you just play
it Bishop to f4 because there's a pin
and if they go here you just crush them
by taking and here white just wins so so
there's some mistakes you can make right
away so much better of course is just to
defend with your king and I okay I'm up
upon I had to make a King move but if I
can just coordinators and get time to
get these out it'll be fine for blacks
so it's White's job to make sure that
doesn't happen
and it's interesting here so we're going
to stop at a moment and I'm going to
show you a game now there's not a whole
lot of theory in these lines due to the
fact that really high rated players
don't do this because they don't like to
be down upon so what the main line is
here is actually Bishop to b2 the idea
is to put your Bishop on c3 which is
very reasonable but there's also this
other idea
it hasn't been prayed played as
frequently but it scores much better
this scores about 60% for white and this
scores about 30% now granted the you
know ratings of the players that have
played this aren't fantastic compared to
some mainline openings but I think it's
you'll get a get a very good indication
of why I think there's a strong case to
be made here for night at four but okay
the main move is Bishop - D - and we'll
just show you black usually gets an
advantage and this move h5 is something
typical for black you might want to get
his pieces out over here on this side of
the board so h5 Mixel
sense also it forces the Queen back
there is a pin here so we can't move too
far away we got to maintain that pin and
it kind of puts the Queen slightly out
of place and okay so we can see in the
line like this now the knight can go to
c4 whereas with the bishop you didn't go
back to c3 because that's where he's
going to put a fish up this is the main
line so something like this could occur
and after this move it becomes obvious
if I have to play g3 well I don't really
have as much compensation for the pawn
as I would like my queen is really out
of place and I don't really see how a
White has any compensation here for the
pawn but if we go back so we return now
okay so this pretends like just play it
King f8 there is this interesting move
Knight to f4 and this will be our first
game for the night
so this is kalinske verse kind enough
was played in 2006 it's one of the
relatively higher either players that
have played this as white 2,400 so we'll
check out what happened here Knight f6
very reasonable develop with tempo you
play Queen h4 and now some funny stuff
there maybe I got some discovery so I'm
back alright they did a little dance but
white being about 200 points higher
rated wanted to win so played the move
Bishop to c4 and now we're beginning to
think about all sorts of sacrifices here
and that's going to be a typical theme
and also black is saying you don't have
any good discoveries move this Knight
anywhere you got nothing so so now the
game gets very interesting clean d6 so
the Queen protects the pond also the
Queen might try to do some sneaky stuff
and come into the white position over
here so obviously why could develop a
piece that would be a fine move but he
went back just to make sure that's not
hanging in any lines
now Queen to b4 with a threat that
hopefully we see okay so the repla into
e2 there should be five doesn't like
getting everything here with tempo well
you did leave the defense of this pawn
but it appears it assumed black was
thinking I'll go here because white
doesn't have time to play Bishop to d2
but white in fact played Bishop to d2
which is the best move
and the reason he probably thought that
is because now I move my queen I'm still
attacking your Bishop and I'm attacking
your rook so if your rook moves away I
take your Bishop and it looks like I'm
going to at least win in exchange here
but in fact White has a very strong move
so here's your first really tough
tactical challenge here it's white to
move and there there is a tactic so I
will give you guys a minute and at home
you can pause and try to solve it then
takes a six is very interesting and this
is actually an okay move it wasn't
played in the game so here I'm like hey
I got to take and then you wanted to do
something here oh but I think here yeah
the trick is you can't take yet because
if you take I take on d2 but you can
play the move you're always trying to
play in this opening Bishop to f4 and
then after the Queen moves pull the
Queen we can take care and this is
actually okay for wipe the sacrifice is
a bit promising so too is the sacrifice
that was played in the game so we
actually took with a different piece on
e6 and we always want to be thinking
about the sacrifices on e6 it's very
typical in this opening did you have it
all right anyone ever told you you're a
very likable guy I just want to I just
want to make that clear
very likable guy in the back with the
right answer okay rook takes c6 very
strong move very strong move and in fact
black blunders here um well the Bishop's
hanging and also the rooks hanging and
he took the wrong thing he took the rook
which loses interesting is taking the
bishop which gives away two very
interesting option you can start with
rook to d1 but for more style you can
take immediately on e7 and what's the
idea well now I play rook to d1 and if
your computer will tell you in this
position you have to take this but okay
going here might also be fine but it
does allow Knight to d5 with lots of
threats everywhere you have to play King
f8 and after you take this you actually
can't take back so you have to find the
movie h5 if you take back we can go here
threatening mate in the rook so white
gets a very powerful attack black might
be able to survive with perfect clay
here but you know it's harder to play
black than it is to play white with
white you just attack your moves are all
forceful and it's a lot easier to play
so any people say with this opening well
it's dubious you lose the pawn right at
the opening but okay I have a certain
level when you're playing here in the
club and you're playing in the quads and
you're playing in the knife well when
something is really complicated you want
to play the side that's easier to play
and why it's just easier to play because
every move is like forceful and you get
to do tactics but let's try to
understand why this move loses
so that's that's right glad you weren't
tempted by this move also very
complicated but you want to take here
which is the best and was played okay
and we're going to do a little little
walk in with the king this looks light
alright something really weird is going
on out there tonight and now I just had
the crushing position because look at
the black King and there's lots of ways
that it could have been achieved I think
here he plays the move we always want to
play know also very strong was Bishop to
f4 because you always want to play
Bishop f4 in this line this also is fine
just look at the King it's running
around stopped rook d1 but rook c1 is
still on and we won't spend too much
time analyzing the rest of this I think
you can kind of get the point
King is probably not going to live there
forever so it's a nice move just
sacrifice that knife and this is the one
last interesting point because white
played a really beautiful move here it's
just a shame it's slightly inaccurate
it's like mayonnaise but you played like
mate nine oh but the move is really
really funny there's lots of moves that
win here the idea is we got to get our
Queen to c1 so all these rook moves are
fine I like it it's only because it was
pretty wasn't the most accurate but it
wasn't the funniest to put the roof back
on a1 normally don't put the rook back
on anyone when there's a pawn on a2 but
here it's protecting the pond and I'm
playing Queens c1 so he went here which
just loses and two moves I guess we can
try to solve a meeting - now you have
lots of moves
lots of moves win but uh yeah Bishop to
c5 this is the most accurate and forced
resignation because now I'm forced down
here and checkmate very good so we can
see all the dangers that can actually be
in store for black if he doesn't decide
to accept all of the pawns here so let's
just let's do the whole thing all over
again just for fun we got a lot of new
people in here so we'll come back to our
main starting point in the French
and Bishop d3 we should I guess just
talk about briefly this move as I said
before it's more accurate to take here
this allows white one additional option
you don't have to do it you could Castle
and then you have the lines that would
kind of looked at but you do have this
option now of taking on c5 and what's
the point well in a lot of lines we're
thinking of just playing b4 and taking
you don't have to go back we're kind of
taking away a lot of squares from your
pieces it's really constricting the
black pieces from the moment you're
attacking f2 so we can cancel and
there's a game I'd like to show you here
where black lofts just like immediately
on this line in that game night h6 was
played the main move is a5 which makes
sense because I'm going to play b4 and
kick you away so you play a5 to stop it
in play might continue as follows now we
can play b4 anyway and after you take I
can take back my knight and threatening
to win the bishop pair I also have the
strong d4 square for my pieces and pawns
are a little weak but it all should be
fine I have this nice strong pawn on e5
all the time so this is how the game
could go off white decides to play this
way I do want to show a game we're black
played to move Knight to h6 and it's
actually a common idea in the French
that sometimes you're willing to allow
this in order to open the G file and
attack the white king when white is
castles in a position like this
so typically players don't end up taking
that night but it's always something
that's worth calculating and so in this
game which is Blomqvist versus holton
from 2015 we're just going to show a a
little miniature here
so I played Queen to e2 very sensible
and now black castle which is already
the losing move and in a lot of these
lines in particular the milner berry
it's a mistake to Castle queenside but
black is often very tempted because
you're thinking of potential attacking
chances over here maybe like I'm just
hoping you open up the G file and I'm
the one
attacking you the here white already has
a really strong attack and it comes a
lot faster than the black attacks those
blacks numbers are doing anything yet
and it begins with B for all right and
you go back it's funny going all the way
to f8 so now if I ever take this then
also your Bishop can come out maybe a
little more if you cook on the e7 but
now a super strong move was played then
it's probably a lot of good moves but
this move is really strong so I will
give you guys a chance here to play the
best move because it's surprising
so Bishop e3 is definitely on the cards
here we do want this to be a thing and
you're forced back here however what I
like about this move and I mean I most
find it great in white still winning
a4 is also grade that's fantastic move
but he made Bishop to e3 even stronger
with this move so understanding Master
Bishop e3 you got to go back to c7 he
played the move Knight to a3 which may
seem a bit unusual because you know I
want to pawn storm you an avalanche and
heck you up but now this is an even
stronger idea because after you go back
I have ideas that might to b5 so very
strong move
you went back and Bishop to e3 all right
and now simple move
which rook I mean some rook yeah it's
probably good for wait I'm still
attacking you he played a simpler move
just does a pawn hanging so we took it
yeah it just took the pond so it's
getting dicey over there and obviously
we're not getting trapped because we
have Bishop to a6 which is very strong
for white so he just took the pawn all
right
usually well you're not really attacking
me then I'm not gonna let you go to f4
and simplex you know I started to get
some counter play he's really going to
try to take on e5 get that strong clown
out of there it's never going to be in
time because he took Knight b5 check and
now took this guy and resigns maybe this
all happened and you save this Bishop
and resigns so just white had just a
really fast attack and black had nothing
going he had no counter play against the
center you ventually got some play here
by maneuvering all of his Knights to
attack this epon but it just wasn't in
time so castling queenside there was a
big mistake but it's a very tempting
option okay but also if they play Bishop
d7 right away we can of course we don't
have to go for that option we could
transpose into what we've already seen
so there's one more line we should take
a look at back in this position after
Knight to c3 we've explored what happens
when they take here but what happens on
the most common move which is actually a
six so their sources will tell you all
right this is the recipe you want to
beat this opening take one pond don't
take the second just play a6 which
prevents any of these nitrogen ana games
and then you also have to retreat your
Queen later so here now Y can take this
opportunity to protect the pond and
White has the positional idea of flying
King h1 so we can play f4 f5 and
sometimes we can get sort of positional
compensation if we can get a weak pawn
on e6 so this is one of the big plans
for white
black generally means you just needs to
solve this coordination problems
immediately there's kind of two pieces
that need to use the square the bishop
and the night so black usually maneuvers
this night over to c6 then you can put
this fish up here another good day he
could safely castle or you can hang out
in the center depending on what white is
attacking so night to e7 is the main
move King h1 Knight to c6 and white can
play f4 and I do want to look at one
last game before we get out of here this
is a special knack off game and our
special costs using the Sicilian player
left it was the world's leading
authority on it just left and he's
playing resumed I EV so to 2500 played
back in 1988 okay and in this game well
I play Knight to b4 which is a very
interesting idea because you're just
going to go after the bishop pair and
what doesn't really have time to save it
so he should play the move rook to d1 if
you decide to play a move like Bishop to
be one like actually has a surprisingly
good option just Queen to c4 which
basically forces a queen trade it's not
so easy to avoid it because if you avoid
it some way I could potentially be
coming down here and still doing some
mean stuff to you so you don't really
have time to do that so you play rook to
d1 alright you grab do this and it still
putting Queen to c4 okay very reasonable
play by both sides III so you go back
and now a very important move was played
very tempting is just to play the move
f5 right away because that's what we
want to do but now this allows a very
strong response by black so black has a
great move here and I will test you guys
see if you guys can find it okay and
it's something that you might not
consider if you've never seen these
types of positions but a very strong
move here where to go
d4
forcing the night to move and there's
not a great place for it the obvious
point is you can't take this because
your nights hanging and if you go for
example here we can just grab that guy
and you have no discovery that's going
to win my queen or anything so here
black is just doing great so that's a
typical thing that you should be looking
for blacks trying to play d4 when you
have a pawn on d5 sometimes they can do
some tricky stuff so f5 doesn't work
right away
so instead why put the bishop on b2 it's
a sensible diagonal for the bishop and
now the knight is protected so if we
play d4 I actually can take it now and
when it's very patient he's going to
play f5 but in the game he really takes
his time he gets all of this stuff
coordinated and then eventually he plays
f5 okay
so white one here there's one piece not
playing so you get that piece into the
game all right very sensible all right
Brooke went to d8 clean f2 which gets
out of the way for the knight now the
knighting maneuver to the d4 square and
he's going to get all those pieces on
just the right squares and eventually
I'm going to play f5 my clean is going
to make sense here if I ever play a5
also I for the moment prevented any of
this ideas that you might have but I'm
also just getting out the way my night
my Knights going to go to d4 and
eventually I'll play a 5 so even though
I'm down upon I'm not like you know in a
big rush because I have positional
compensation and castled 9 to d4
Queen d7 so we got all of our stuff and
good places and so finally f5 waited
till we were good and ready and okay so
how is not going to meet this the game
he took don't have to take but you took
number to g3 I also like this too in a
lot of these positions that were about
to see you can always just take back
stuff which is a good move but you
really just wanted to improve all of
this stuff first and after the move g6
doesn't really protect this pawn because
we can still take it but you didn't take
it right away again just improve this
pieces and you play it clean f4 how mean
and I'm still going to take this and
then I also control this square so now
I'm hoping to take with my knife and
then pull my dad on h6 that looks really
strong so rook e8 so that our Bishop
will come back and defend now Knight
takes bishop f8 and I leave here you
played another strong move Knight h6
attempting and probably good but Bishop
D for not allowing black to push and
open up this bishop so it's we always
want to use this d4 square for our
pieces because it's available to us and
especially with the bishop here we want
to keep this on lockdown otherwise
blacks going to get lots of counter play
but ok we blocked that so he's trying to
do some defending and now he goes in and
virtually wins the bishop hair you have
to take it we take back rook here and
it's just not really easy to move as
black you know it's just kind of
uncomfortable so we're just still
squeezing you now here which is actually
the losing blunder black is thinking
about sometimes trying to sack here and
then you offer I take back we're going
to go up in exchange for then
maybe I get to play d4 and good stuff
might happen but there's actually a
winning move here for white and it
requires a little bit of calculation so
I'll give you guys a chance you want to
pause at home this again is a tough idea
to see at least directly because you
want to think about how black plans on
defending a little bit but but take your
time and I'll see what you guys come up
with
yes on route to h3 what is black have in
mind as a defensive resource you can't
move the King because I'm yeah white
okay yeah let's play in the game so
guarding the edge pawn is pretty serious
business that's five yeah so this has to
be played this doesn't work but okay but
what now yeah don't don't do this by
lateral defense
also how many people in this room know
this move is illegal people probably
don't know that's a big hint yeah I'm
the font he said it okay yeah very good
then and that's this is very strong pawn
you know I'm coming here very strong so
in the game he tried to blockade all
right very sensible idea and we're it
not for White's next move black is doing
great I mean black has a tendon but
unfortunately white can really break
through here and just win
push the Queen to the pond right I
tricked you with my language but that
was played in the game okay
testing you um yeah no very strong move
and black resigned the idea is if we
take now we push the idea is you can't
take because of work eight shape so you
would have to go here giving us the
Queen what's funny is you know you
obviously you can take your check and
then pick up the Queen but this is even
stronger because your route can't even
move out of the way
you can't go here because the works
going to h8 again you can't go over here
work h8 so your guy just has to stay
there and die and you go here and I make
a queen and you resign yeah you know
you're not going to last long here so
I'm thinking of in this position after I
take after rook to e1 which is a good
suggestion
I'm wondering about taking here I'm just
wondering that is if you take I push so
we're going to get something very
similar does it still work so here I
actually do have to take here I think
yeah so I don't know check so you have
to take check and then I pick up your
plan so it looks like it works also
thinking about it it also probably means
I can go here too because then doing the
same stuff to you like this so I'll go
here and I take a yeah so just bad stuff
is happening here and this is sort of a
typical model game that can happen even
white it was down upon the whole time he
just was really squeezing and got all
this stuff to the right places and built
up very slowly his attack and the reason
you play this as white is because even
if you don't
checkmate them right away or they don't
fall for the trap right at the very
beginning of the opening it's much
easier just to play with white because
it's easier when your pieces are great
and you can move them all to great
squares and black has to defend very
very accurately so I'll leave the I'll
leave it to you guys in the comments
below to tell me what you think of a
gambit is it just a blunder of a pond or
does white have tons of compensation
I'll let you guys fight about it in the
comments so make sure you hit like share
subscribe and thanks everybody for
coming out tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]